hey everyone is Sears registered are
sorry and calm and in this video I want
to demonstrate for you how to irrigate a
cloth to mate so what is the purpose of
irrigating a colostomy it removes soles
from the colon using an enema which is
usually warm water and it can be
anywhere from the male as 500 CCS to a
thousand depending on what the physician
orders and it's an enema given through
the stoma so sink under eyes an enema
that you would give through the rectum
it's sort of doing the same thing but
we're using the stoma and this is
usually a physician's order you have
come in order to do this and they may
order this if the patient isn't putting
out a lot of school through there so
maybe they're constipated or the patient
has chose to do bowel training and
patients what they can do whenever
they're doing bowel training they can
train their colon to put out at a
certain time during those irrigations so
they'll leave free from wearing a
continuous pouch throughout the day
which we'll be putting out school
throughout the day so it gives them some
free time now what are some key points
to remember about this ok patients who
are going to have the best success with
irrigating McCloskey are patients with
descending and sigmoid colostomies why
why are they going to have the best
success well let's look back at the
anatomy we have over here or colon and
we have the descending and the sigmoid
now whatever the patient has one of
these awesome e's they have majority of
their large intestine still there and
what is the role of the large intestine
remember from our last video over cost
means an ileostomy
the role of the colon is to absorb water
so as the school travels through here
the water is getting absorbed so once it
hits this area the stool is going to be
more formed so it's gonna be easier to
irrigate and get our bowel trained so
and you may see the ostomy over here
where which would be a descending or you
may see it over here which would be a
sigmoid now patients who have an
ileostomy are not candidates for this
because the stole that's coming out
connected over
iliyan these patients have liquid stool
it's never form and it's very rich in
electrolytes and fluid so we don't want
to be messing with that area so they're
not a candidate for this now whatever
you're doing bowel training the patient
needs to know that it's going to take
about six to eight weeks to get the
colon trained so they need to know that
it takes a little bit of time and a lot
of dedication but can have good result
for them if they choose to do this not
all patients choose to do this and the
result will be like I said earlier and
they will not have any bowel movements
in between that irrigation and it frees
them up from wearing that pouch and said
they will wear a stomach hop over the
stoma which is a very small closed pouch
system and they'll perform the
irrigations once they get trained maybe
every day or every other days depending
on the patient's bowel habits now some
other things whenever you're training
the bowel you'll want to teach the
patient and perform this at the same
time every day why because we want the
colon to get used to putting out its
contents at a certain time every day so
a patient can pick what time works great
for them to do this and get the colon
used to it and you're going to perform
it best time is about one hour after a
meal because this is when the colon is
fullest you're going to get the most
success of helping it get empty and as
on earth what you want to remember and
let the patient know this because this
process takes time from start to finish
it takes about one hour so about five to
ten minutes for actually instilling the
fluid through the stoma and then another
30 to 45 minutes for the colon to empty
itself generally it comes out and
episodes with stool will and burped it
takes about 30 45 minutes for it to be
completely emptied so keep that in mind
and this is normally either performed in
the bathroom with the commode or in the
bed with the bedpan whatever you choose
to do and whatever the patient wants to
do now let me go over the supplies that
you will need to perform this you will
need an ear
Gatien bag that holds at least a
thousand cc's of water you will be
putting in warm water in this bag
generally you don't give any more than a
thousand cc's it's usually between five
hundred to a thousand also it will come
with some tubing and you may have to
connect the tubing to the cone because
this cone will be used to insert into
the stoma when you give the enema
and you'll just connect it right here
and then here is your little regulator
that you will turn on or off as you're
letting the water and still into the
stoma then you will need an irrigation
sleeve this is where the water in the
stool is going to collect and once it
starts draining out and a lot of times
these sleeves come with a clip and this
clip will go at the end of the sleeve
just to close it shut so the contents
doesn't fill out while you're doing this
sometimes people just cut this bag to
the certain length of what they need and
put it inside the commode or the bedpan
and just allow the contents to flow
through that but for this demonstration
we're going to be using the clip and
we'll be emptying it that way and I
wanted to show you this this is a flange
it goes over the summit's part of the
two-piece system and what you will do if
a patient's we're having a two-piece
system you will just simply take your
irrigation sleep and just clip it snap
it on to the barrier so whenever you are
doing this procedure it allow the stoma
to let the contents collect in the sleep
but if you're using a one-piece system
you'll need to get a face play and it
ostomy belt to help you do that so make
sure that you get the right supplies
before you start this procedure also
another thing you'll need is water
soluble lubricant because you will be
using this to lubricate the comb before
you insert it into the stoma you will
need several pairs of gloves because
you'll be changing them in between and
also it's a good idea to wear a gown to
protect your skin and your scrubs from
getting a splash with stool in the
contents coming out especially if you're
going to just be letting it drain down
into the commode or the
bedpan because there's a risk of
splashing and you'll want some
washcloths with warm water to provide
stoma care before and after the
procedure and some towels just to
protect the patient's gown first perform
hand hygiene then turn on your gown and
glove
now fill your irrigation bag up with
warm water and before you do to have the
trick
make sure your regulator is in the off
position because you don't want to fill
it up and all your water spills out
after you fill the bag you will want to
hang it and hang the bag where the
bottom of the bag is about shoulder
linked to the patient because you want
it at this level so the solution doesn't
go in too fast which can cause some
discomfort and cramping for the patient
now so we have water in our bag but the
most important thing you want to do is
you want to prime this tubing just like
you would an IV to me because we don't
want all this air going into the
patient's guts going to cause them some
major discomfort so what you want to do
is you just want to open the valve up a
little bit on your regulators remember
we closed that when we filled it and
we're just going to fill this whole
tubing with water so I'm going to open
it and it's going through there we're
making sure we get all the air bubbles
out and there we go okay so our tubing
is nice and prime and we're ready to go
now what you want to do is you want to
clean the summer you want to remove any
soil that may be on it so you'll just
take a washcloth with warm water and
just gently clean the area
make sure it's nice and clean then
dispose of that and then what we want to
do we want to lubricate our smallest
finger and what we're going to do is
we're going to be inserting it into the
stomach because we want to feel the
angle of how the bowel is because that's
how we're going to insert our cone so
just put a little lubricant on the
finger and whenever you insert into the
soem be aware that it can tense up or
freeze up a little bit and if that
happens just stop and then let it relax
and then gently feel dull force so just
going to gently just fill the angle okay
now what we're going to do is we're
going to change our gloves perform hand
hygiene and put on a new pair of gloves
now we're going to attach our irrigation
sleeve on to the faceplate of the flange
now and before you do this if you're not
using the commode or a bedpan which
would allow the stool to go into that
you're instead you're going to clip that
I don't forget to clip your bag so take
the clip and then just take it towards
the end of the bag and just snap it shut
and then take your irrigation sleeve and
if you're using the two-piece system
you'll just attach to this if you're
using the one-piece you'll use the
faceplate and ostomy belt and it'll just
snap on there and stay in place
okay now we're going to lubricate the
comb but first what you want to do is
you want to open that bag as the
irrigation sleeve a little bit first
because you're going to get lubricant on
your hands and when glit gloves and
lubricant do not go together it's really
slippery so we've opened the sleeve of
the irrigation sleeve and then we're
going to lubricate the cone and get it
nice and lubricated so it's easier to
insert into the stoma and it's not
painful for the patient so after you get
a lubricated you're going to go
in and remember what angle that the
summer was at so that will be the angle
that you insert the cone and you insert
it just enough without causing too much
force but you want it in enough where
you when you instill the contents it
doesn't leak out now you're going to
open up the valve of the irrigation bag
by turning it to on and you're going to
do it slowly so and the water goes in
slowly you don't want it too fast or too
slow if the patient starts reporting
cramping or nausea turn it back off let
them feel better have them take a breath
and then start slowly again and remember
this process takes about five to ten
minutes and we want it all of this in
views of what the doctor ordered after
you've instilled all of the water wait
about 10 seconds then remove the cone
from the stoma and dispose about
properly and then be sure to fill the
sleeve of the irrigation sleeve and have
the patient hold the contents for about
30 to 45 minutes and you will notice
that over that time spurts of stool and
irrigation fluid value and still will
come seeping out and it will look
something like this and as you can see
here the Arrogant in the stool has come
out and what we're going to do is we're
going to remove this irrigation sleeve
and we're going to provide Soumik hair
replace the flange the skin barrier and
you'll want to chart this per your
hospital protocol however they require
and you'll want to talk about what
you've done how you explained it to the
patient how they tolerated it and how
much and came out whenever you measured
it and your documentation could look
something similar like this if you are
using the FDR format okay so this wraps
up how to irrigate a cloth
to me thank you so much for watching and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more videos